welcome adventurer to an RPG unlike any
other in a world forsaken by the gods
that people need you to become their
next divinity before you venture forth
into the huge and sprawling realm of
river LAN however you need to decide
what role he will play become a hottie
lizard perhaps a flesh-eating elf or
even an undead dwarf
or take on the role of one of six origin
stories each with their own unique
history and talents I was destined to
become the next Emperor during your
journey
these heroes can also be recruited as
companions right you are lead the way
your personality and background will
determine your dialogue choices quests
and challenges as you journey to replace
the lost divine unfortunately there can
only be one so the relationships within
your party shall be put to the test but
before we get there we have an
astonishing number of things to do the
friend animals grow wings teleport
enemies of friends into burning pits of
fire
sneak steal talk to ghosts and even rip
the faces of dead bodies to create you
shape-shifting Mars craft equipment or
pizza and use your powers of persuasion
to get yourself out of sticky situations
and if things don't go your way you can
always fight your way out
combat is dynamically turn-based during
your turn look for opportunities to use
elements and terrain to your advantage
exploit your strengths and your enemy's
weaknesses but remember your foods will
try to do the same the world of divinity
original sin - extends beyond rhythm
hone your skills and challenge your
friends in the arena's of the PvP use
the game master mode to create your own
campaign filled with custom monsters and
counters and maps then lead a party of
friends throw your handcrafted adventure
you shall die so go forth brave
adventurer alone or with friends online
or in split-screen no matter how you
choose to play you will experience
endless layers of pen-and-paper RPG
death neatly packaged as the visually
exciting often unpredictable and always
dramatic world of original
[Music]
you